the nation will fall silent today at
11AM to remember all of those who have
given their lives for this country in
Conflict since the first world war the
service at the cenotaph in London will
be particularly poignant because it is
going to be the first led by the king
since the passing of his late Majesty uh
the queen now our security and defense
editor Deborah Haynes spoke to the chief
of the defense staff Admiral Sir Tony
radican for this program they discussed
the war in Ukraine and also pressures on
defense spending but she began by asking
about remembrance
I think remembrance Sunday is always
poignant I think it's poignant for the
whole nation this special moment when we
pause to reflect on the sacrifice and
commitment of others to provide our
freedom today
I think there's a special poignancy this
year with both the loss of her majesty
another loss of a second world war
veteran and I also think it's poignant
when we have once again the Specter of
war in Europe
and all that that entails and a country
that's been invaded and is fighting for
its freedom we're remembering the um
those who gave their lives in the first
and the second world wars and like you
said right now Europe has War once again
on its soil How likely is it that this
could actually escalate into the Third
World War
I think what you've seen we're
approaching now nearly nine months
is that the war is relatively contained
in terms of geography
the impact of the war is enormous that's
Global the impact on food prices the
impact on millions of people and whether
or not they were going to get the grain
that Ukraine provides the impact on all
of us whether it's inflation or the
energy crisis and I think those are all
a reminder that even though the war
itself might be relatively physically
contained what it means is millions of
people that have been displaced from
their country millions of people that
are being attacked and they're losing
their energy or their water doesn't work
anymore millions of people fighting for
their freedom
that's what you're seeing and tens of
thousands of people that are dying or
are injured and and it's that reminder
that these precious values of of freedom
of democracy of that your territory is
your own and that when that's attacked
then the right people defend those and
they fight to get them back
we're talking
um just after Russia has given this
order to withdraw its treats from
Hearthstone City in the south of Ukraine
how significant is that
I think it's significant in the sense
that once again you're seeing Russia
fail Russia's failed on all of its
strategic objectives it wanted to
subjugate Ukraine the opposite is hap
has happened Ukraine is fighting for its
freedom it wanted to take control of the
Cities you saw that fail it wanted to to
weaken NATO NATO is stronger and now
you're seeing a war that inevitably at
the Tactical level has twists and turns
but you're seeing a Russia under
pressure
taking Desperate Measures that's why
he's had to mobilize additional people
but it's it's got to try and overcome
a nation that's fighting for its freedom
a nation that we're supporting alongside
lots of other International countries
whether that's cash whether that's
Armament whether that's ammunition
for your U.S counterpart
um General Mark milley has said that the
withdrawal um in herthon could provide a
window of opportunity for negotiations
between the two sides what do you think
I think that those windows will be
determined by
president zielinski and President Putin
and undoubtedly the Tactical events
might open those windows a little bit
more
but we've got to respect that Ukraine is
fighting for its territory its future
its survival
and this is a success for Ukraine but at
the same time Ukraine continues to be
attacked Ukraine has lost ground that it
needs to win back Ukraine has got
millions of people that are not living
in their homes they're either living
elsewhere in Ukraine or in the rest of
Europe they've got millions of people
that are suffering from the impacts of
the electrical infrastructure having
been attacked or the water
infrastructure being attacked it is a
war crime to to a to to deliberately
attack civilians and and that's what's
still going on and is there any change
in your assessment on the likelihood of
Russia backed into a corner resorting to
a nuclear strike in Ukraine I think
we've got to be really careful of of of
Reckless rhetoric where
where the these noises are made about
about nuclear whether it's a dirty bomb
or it's a tactical nuclear weapon we
should be really careful about that
language that would be another
total
horrific step and we don't see that that
we're on a pathway to to that to that
particular Specter and we've also got to
be really clear that if we started to go
down that path that it would lead to
incredibly serious consequences but
where none of us are on that path and
Russia I think has tried to to reassure
in that sense and I think we've been
really clear as to how dangerous that
that particular route would be
um Sky News reported this week about
claims that Russia has transported
captured British and law anti-tank
missiles
U.S anti-tank javelins and U.S Stinger
anti-aircraft missiles to Iran along
with loads of cash 122 million pounds
worth in cash in exchange for dozens of
drones these deadly Char head drones
that they've been using that Russia's
been using in Ukraine were you aware of
this so I went I won't go into the
detail of intelligence reports but we've
always been aware that when we provide
some of our weaponry and it's going into
a war zone there's a risk that that
Weaponry might be captured and and so
what I can offer you is that the the
technology that we're talking about is
technology of 20 30 years ago and then
that technology is used in the
manufacturing process to provide the
weapons of today and and so I we're
conscious that when we provide Armament
and support to a Ukraine that's in in a
war then there might be some of those
weapons that end up being captured and
that's taken into account when when
we'll go through our assessment as to
what's going to be provided so are you
going to do anything about it if Iran is
trying to develop end-laws
so we're in a constant competition with
certain Nations it's very much the case
with Iran but it's
it's a it's a fact that when you provide
your weapons to to Country X
in the middle of a war they may not
necessarily stay in country X the
chancellor is going to be giving his
Autumn statement on Thursday how
confident are you that defense will be
protected from the impact of inflation
and foreign exchange
I can't go into the detail of of of a
financial statement statement that's
that's that's going to be announced
later this week but what I can
offer you is the seriousness with which
the situation is being discussed we have
a prime minister he's been prime
minister for just over two weeks he's
had numerous conversations with the
defense secretary with me about the
security situation in Europe but also
the globe but we specifically had an
hour with the Prime Minister and the
chancellor and I accompanied the defense
secretary
to talk about
what would be the impact of their
financial settlement and and to the the
richness and the seriousness of that
conversation recognizing that this war
in Europe is part of the reason why we
have the level of inflation that we have
and why we have the economic pressure
and therefore in trying to deal with the
economic pressure
we need to acknowledge that at its core
is this security pressure in Europe and
and the government is is having the
right level of conversation to try and
manage that but also manage the security
situation into the future so that's why
you're seeing a conversation about
coming back to the integrated review of
last year and and taking time to to
assess that again what what what what is
working what do we want to affirm and
what might we want to adjust and and
recognize because of the increased
aggression of Russia we we need to
adjust some of the risks that we were
taking and that might mean in the longer
term more investment but let's have that
com that that longer term conversation
as well the government keeps saying
there needs to be economic stability in
order to have things like defense
spending do you think they're now
realizing that there cannot be economic
stability without security and in terms
of having security you need therefore to
invest fully in defense
absolutely and I think you saw that with
last year's integrated review an
integrated review that tried to take
integration review that's not going to
be funded unless this
gives you
illian Powell pounds according to the
defense secretary himself over the next
two years are you going to get this 8
billion pounds so I can't I can't I
can't go into the specifics but what
happens if you don't get it so again I I
think it will be wrong to to start
talking about if we don't get it then it
means this this and this those
conversations are being had with the
Prime Minister and the chancellor their
private conversations I can assure you
that those conversations are being had
they're the right conversations and
they're being blended with what was said
in last year's integrated review what
needs to be shaped for the longer term
future but also to recognize the the
immediate economic pressure of the
country is under but also recognized as
a war in Europe and that that the the
seriousness of those conversations are
being had and that's the Assurance I can
give you I'm sure they're serious but if
they don't end up with with eight
billion pounds for defense over the next
two years then they're meaningless it
means defense has to shrink would you
resign if that happens so so we've got
to wait and see what the Autumn
statement says I think we've got to be
really cautious of of of of of the risk
of being a bit too shrill and saying
like if if this happens then I'm going
to yeah yeah this person is going to
resign and that I I'm much more in their
space of the right conversations are
being had let's wait and see what the
Autumn statement says let's take stock
then let's recognize there's a blend
going on of economic pressures that have
to be serviced and security pressures
that have to be service and the right
conversations are being had to allow to
allow those solutions to emerge